hi there in this short video i'm going
to show you how to use the translation
features embedded in microsoft word to
translate text documents into the
variety of different languages supported
by microsoft translator
alright let's get started
today i received a word document with a
memo from a team i work with in germany
the documents in german but luckily i
can use the translator features in word
to translate it automatically
to translate the text i simply
select the text i want to translate
click on the review tab in the ribbon at
the top of the screen
choose translate
and select translate selected text
a window will appear on the right where
you can choose the languages you want to
translate to
here is a list of all the supported
languages
i want to translate this document from
german
to english
i can then decide to either copy it to
use elsewhere in this document or simply
insert it to replace the original text
if you want to translate an entire
document
click on translate document from
translate under the review tab after you
click on the icon a window will pop up
letting you know that this document will
be sent to microsoft translator
press send
and the translation will open up in a
new tab of your internet browser
if you have to do multiple translations
or need to use the translate feature on
a regular basis i would recommend adding
the translation menu to the quick access
toolbar by going to
more commands at the top of the window
select the review tab from commands
choose translate and press add
and choose ok
now you can quickly select the phrase
you want to translate
click on the shortcut
and there you go
you may have noticed that when i opened
the translate menu there is another
option called mini translator
the mini translator gives you a pop-up
window with a translation every time you
select a sentence or hover over a word
in microsoft word
you can select the language of the mini
translator by choosing choose
translation language in the translation
menu
when you activate the mini translator it
will stay active until you deactivate it
within the translation menu
when the mini translator is activated
you'll see a pop-up window with a
translation that you can copy
or even play the sound of the original
text
this mini translator is also available
in powerpoint outlook and onenote
i hope this video has been useful in
demonstrating the translation features
embedded in word
for more videos about microsoft
translator check out our youtube channel
at www
dot aka dot ms
slash translator youtube
thanks a lot